we've got meltdown come at me we've got
man versus man and we've got mega
rejections go find someone will have a
mediocre life with it's time for roses
and roses a 100 oh my this is our 100th
episode of roses and Rose a ever are you
kidding me Lauren congratulations on
your hundredth episode of roses and Rose
a just taking a quick coffee break
although I wish it was a rose a break
wanted to wish you a happy 100th episode
of roses and Rose a you guys kill a
great job congratulations
today is the hundredth episode of roses
and Rose hey well that's amazing that
anyone would watch that thing 400 times
you must they must have great guests on
and they do I'm so proud of you and you
keep killing it
give us the recaps and I cannot wait for
the hana recaps here's 100 more girl you
rock miss you love you love the show
mwah very very big congratulations to
your 100th episode that's amazing Warren
and the team congratulations on a
hundred episodes that is something to be
proud of
it's pretty amazing I remember a nice
season I'd wait each and every week and
I froze the Rose Aynak amount so I knew
exactly what I did wrong that week but
congratulations and years of the next
100
Rachel
congratulations on your episode
now bachelor nation is super strong and
I just wanted to congratulate her and
say cheers all of you hi Lauren Congrats
on your 100th episode recap on roses and
rose a Garrett and I are happy to be
part of the bachelor nation with you so
here's to 100 more Congrats [ __ ] I'm
hosting such a good show can't wait to
watch more congratulations you are the
greatest hoes out there can't believe
we've had a hundred episodes I'm ready
congratulations and here's to 100 more
yay hey Lauren Congrats on your 100th
episode of roses and Rose eh
I am a huge fan and I am celebrating
with you
so keep killing the game girl love you a
hundred episodes of roses and rose a
that is golfing your ball
congratulations
so i'm lauren zima of course thank you
guys for 100 episodes this is so amazing
my heart is warmed and that's saying a
lot
and I just love doing the show with you
and JC you'll see him later in the
episode I know you want to see him I
know he loves me okay he's coming at me
too so we are now going to get into in
honor of Hanna Brown being a 15th season
ever of The Bachelorette what a
milestone what a moment
b15 most dramatic moments ever in
Bachelorette history thank you for
leaving your suggestions on the moments
and to get me through it all yes this is
an absolutely massive glass of Rose a
you can't see the wine you guys but it
is a rose a colored chalice and I want
to recommend these to you I love to
educate the people if I can if you don't
know yet about these types of glasses
they're like stainless steel double
insulated situations they keep things
quite cold and I find that quite
convenient for Rose a I have a water
bottle made of
this and I put Rosie and I take it to
the beach no I don't I'm not sure if
that's legal is that legal it depends on
the beach I do it sometimes when it's
legal okay
please drink responsibly here we go
moment 15 I don't know how to act don't
really don't Palin Bristow's season 11
premiere of The Bachelorette we're gonna
see Kaitlyn Bristowe on this countdown a
lot because booboo brought it on her
season as did the men Shawn booth Lyle
lots of other dudes anyway we're getting
into it so number 15 though is another
woman the rejection of Britt remember
this was the only time in Bachelorette
history that there have been two
bachelorettes fighting to become the
Bachelorette on the premiere it was
never done again because fans found it a
bit offensive and I'll be honest angry
doesn't send the best message the guys
voted and poor Britt was voted off the
mansion unfortunately you're not going
to be the best friend she was sent home
in tears all our love to you Britt hope
you're doing well but did love Kaitlyn
season and we thought she was the better
choice okay number 14 still on Kaitlyn's
season we're grouping a couple moments
into one here cuz I couldn't leave these
mani meltdowns out yes it is a multiple
male meltdowns from Kaitlyn's men very
quickly and dawn calling can't went out
for allegedly being shallow and surface
level I feel like you're here to make
out with a bunch of dudes on TV I really
see you as a surface level person at
this stage super offended by you that in
the car he said he'd make a good patch
where are you
nowhere where's Kaitlyn she has podcasts
and millions of followers
she won
[Music]
and then there was the JJ versus Clint
man on man action and yes I'm saying man
on man action because these two bros
took a turn for the worse
we thought they might brawl it out and
come to blows but they didn't they just
brode it out all for show you know
people say girl fights well we're gonna
say boy fights today drink for every boy
fight walk away from me I won't thank
you you're welcome
[Music]
moment number 13 one of Jojo Fletcher's
breakups poor chase McNary he was a
pretty even guy all season long but he
lost it during the break-up I just
jumped over a hurdle that I've never
done before and now I'm skewered I know
I don't know I'm shattered I will never
forget him popping that take a beer just
needing a drink all our love to you
chase and number 12 another Jojo Momo
JoJo's break up with Luke tell you guys
this is on the countdown because Luke
was dumbfounded the drama was in his
pure shock and Jojo was left in tears
let's take a moment tell me what you
think of our moments so far should we
have put chase above Luke Luke above
chase which breakup hit you hardest I
have to say it's interesting to have
hindsight here because now some of the
ways that Luke has acted make me not as
upset about that breakup but in that
time of watching that breakup happen on
TV my heart was crackled in multiple
pieces and that's difficult for
something that's already quite small
moment number 11 this is a bigger
throwback Ali Fedotowsky season season 6
her split with Frank oh this was a case
of a contestant self exiting aka Frank
breaking Ali's heart
I remember watching this at home and
feeling that Frank was the clear
front-runner Ali was so into him and
then he left her because he still had
feelings for another woman I went to
Chicago to see Nicole Nicole Nicole our
friend Nicole still together did that
work out for the best Frank
if anybody know and let me know I'll try
to do some digging but I didn't before
this cuz I don't care that much you know
why because Frank broke Ali's heart and
I don't support that Frank I don't
support you breaking our bachelorettes
heart though good thing you didn't lead
her on because we're gonna have some
leading on liar moments on this
countdown to which is worse to break up
with someone honestly and horribly
painfully or to lie there's a right
answer there everybody okay anyway
moment number 10 this wasn't what I
would call a breakup so much as a boot
out Rachel Lindsey kicking Demario off
her season before they were even really
together enough to call it a breakup yes
before the bachelor in paradise scandal
remember that Demario had a different
scandal on Rachel Lindsey season of The
Bachelorette I put it all out on the
court like the same way I do in life
there on this basketball court and the
game takes a turn review player enters
yeah okay game play she's on the offense
I've lost it Karma's a [ __ ] isn't it
Dorian oh you don't know if they'll have
the keys to my apartment but Rachel goes
off on jamario because this woman comes
on the show I mean it was clearly a
setup moment and says her and Mario had
been dating to Mario's caught in a lie
this girl shows the receipts of the text
message
rachel is scrolling through that phone
and she tells him to get out I'm really
gonna need you to get the out I think
what made this woman so incredibly
dramatic is that not only did Rachel
seem frustrated with tip Mario but
Ayanna's loopy she was frustrated with
production - this is not what I signed
up for I remember she like stormed off
she was like I don't play like this I'm
putting my personal life and Mario's
just standing on you can see the wheels
spinning he's trying to figure out what
he can say in this moment and he just
like correct correct definitely 100
correct dude definitely 100% correct
definitely I didn't lie I did well I'm
not dating her well I broke up with her
okay well she's right there saying not
to lie and hope she has the text
messages okay definitely correct I'm
gonna be in my sweatband or leaving now
[Applause]
only got more dramatic from there for
tomorrow
all right moment number nine we're back
to season six you guys this is one of my
all-time favorite moments in all
Bachelor shows you know Justin I think
it's been especially difficult for you
cuz
you probably miss your girlfriend in
Canada Ali Fedotowsky calling out Justin
rated-r and his broken leg for having a
girlfriend while he was on the show
Justin Tuck like a man first of all she
breaks up with him but that's not even
the dramatic part it's that he then
storms off really the most anti-climatic
way because his leg is broken so he's
limping away from Ali trying to escape
her as she's chasing him down at a very
slow pace this is not a high-speed chase
situation in fact I was almost worried
he might injure himself further he goes
through the bushes he tries to open
locked doors and all the while in
masterful editing the voice mails from
his girlfriend are playing absolutely
iconic production how does this show not
having any how I think the Emmys are
treating reality TV the way that the
Oscars are treating superhero movies and
comedies they're overlooking them then
your statues give enemies to the Petra
franchise and give enemies to the Real
Housewives just bring my casket to my
wider okay okay okay
I've said it and I'll drink to that and
drink to that at home a few great Emmys
anyway anyway moment number 8 told you
we'd have a little more gyeom guy action
[Music]
this might have been the biggest baddest
villain in Bachelorette history bad boy
Chad Johnson's here everybody asleep
last night with a mimosa and a robe on
even watch the show mm now he was
flat-out offensive to Sarah hair on on
bachelor in paradise when he made fun of
her body but before that on The
Bachelorette cuz that's what we're
talking about he got in fights with Evan
bass the sweetest man he got in a fight
with Jordan Rogers and we thought
those arguments might come to blows in
fact she'll threaten violence when you
go home you think I can't find you you
think I won't go out of my way to come
to your house not cool babe all right
guys we're fully in the top ten now and
I know that the order might blow your
mind or make you mad so leave your
comments and thoughts did I get this
order right you can call me out
I'm calling other people speaking of
criticism in questioning number seven is
Nick Viall asking Andi Dorfman why she
made love to him it's not sure why
like why you made love a thing I don't
this one is absolutely legendary on Andy
Dorfman's
after the final rose special Nick had
been rejected by her she chosen Josh
Marie and he asked Andy she didn't love
him like why you made love with me I
don't
well first of all I think that's coming
below the belt I think that's something
that should be private and kept private
that drama didn't lie in fights it
didn't lie I'm gonna break up it didn't
lie in a discovered girlfriend you just
lie in emotional pain and trauma and
absolute pitifulness really all our love
to Nick and Andy quite a TV moment again
unending drink every time the
bachelor/bachelorette deserting I mean
hmm
six Emily Maynard oh my girl she was a
southern lady with sass something got
brought to my attention and Jalen you're
on the spot last night as I understand
it Ricki was referred to as baggage and
when she found out that Kailen Kailen
Kailen Kailen I don't know he sounds
like a villain in the Superman movie but
she found out that he had called her
daughter baggage baggage
oh she lets him have it you have
anything to say for yourself it's not
always the contestants bringing the
drama on this countdown
sometimes it's the bachelorettes
themselves and she told him to get the
app out is there anything you can say to
say no I didn't say that no not at all
they get that out God is it really adds
a lot to tell someone to get out to add
the effort in there doesn't it yeah out
get out okay I got a haven't had an
opportunity to do that in my life or
maybe I'm just I've just always had a
little wine and some quite Placid I got
to get mad at somebody
yep out
how do you really feel we have gone from
terror to tears this is one of the
bachelorettes most brutal breakups ever
Brooks dumping Desiree I think it's so
painful not just because she is
red-faced and sobbing but also because
it happened in Antigua so it's set on
this back trouble like a beautiful blue
water they were supposed to have a date
together and Brooks breaks up with her
and it's one of those heart-wrenching
breakup swear he doesn't have a super
particular reason he's just not feeling
it you don't see it lasting after I'm
feeling rough it's not like oh the time
he doesn't work or you live here it's
just like I don't live with you I mean
you can't write this ha I would love to
see Meryl Streep doing a reading of
scenes from the bachelor or bachelorette
like Meryl Streep and Radley Cooper get
me that movie Marilyn Bradley
Meryl sings I miss a star is born you
guys I really do baby it's down
number four a breakup that broke my
heart can you guess what's gonna be
Rachel Lindsay and Boehner Oh
Peter he hasn't been on our screens in
some time we never got a paradise we
never got a Winter Games what a
throwback this is making me feel so
nostalgic for his salt-and-pepper hair
and his sweaters and his model good
looks uh Rachel and Peter splitting was
gut-wrenching
go find someone will have a mediocre
life with it was the break-up that
wouldn't end she ended it and then they
like hugged they ended it and they
kissed they ended it and then they were
both crying oh they knew it wasn't right
but that was splitting was also so wrong
I'm not a physical attraction there I
think remember that hot tub makeout
scene let's just remember that
[Music]
okay next Jillian Harris bachelorette
number five Wes do you guys remember
this it turned out Wes had had a
girlfriend the entire time he was on the
show and he made it far and when things
smiley went south he bragged about it
shot me down I'm going down to flames
the first guy ever on The Bachelor to
make it to the top four with a
girlfriend he boasted about how long
he'd been on the show with a girlfriend
I don't drink to you Wes good right at
countries but perhaps worse than Wes and
weigh in in the comments was Bentley on
Ashley Jabir season who was worse guys
Wes or Bentley I put badly a little bit
above because he said even meaner crap
didn't he
Valley goes to break up with Ashley and
he is a guy who she has sworn is so
sincere and that's what attracts heard
him so much and he says he's gonna go
make her cry he says that he asks how
his hair is going to look during it only
on the bachelor bachelorette do you find
this kind of dumpster fire of a human
okay and I'm gonna shy about saying that
because who does that Bentley the moment
that takes the cake our number one the
most dramatic Bachelorette moment in all
15 seasons of the show's history is
where does this table sound so weird
drop is it my cool glass is that's a
problem hold on oh that was it
not very musical do you wanna go back my
hard to anything out for that yeah
Kaitlyn Bristowe and Nick vials trouble
the tryst
oh I remember watching this like it was
yesterday
and not because I rewatched it yesterday
because I really do remember it Kaitlyn
had feelings for Sean I had feelings for
Nick the two had been head-to-head all
season long and then she before the
fantasy suites takes Nick behind closed
doors the door closes we only hear and
that's what made this woman so dramatic
again the editing quality Emmy worthy we
heard them whispering sweet nothings to
each other the implication was clear if
not over the top and a little bit
obnoxious but it was absolutely
enthralling television
[Music]
and after that Caitlyn on a balcony
questioning her decisions clearly
talking to a producer was that a frame
but it made it look like she was talking
to know when I'm going a little nuts
from what she'd done waking up in the
morning I definitely am feeling guilt
okay you guys
these have been our 15 most dramatic
Bachelorette moments in the show's
history all leading up to Hannah Browns
season thank you so much for watching
thank you for being here let me know if
you agree with me or disagree leave the
comments below in the depths and of
course he has to come say hi JC can you
come give a wave to the people
that's dramatic is my extreme center
part and slicked-back ponytail and you
want deep side part chase you look very
slick today
let's just finish our wine for how
good-looking JC is I can't there's so
much I'm sure there's so much I'm here
we love you guys let's blow an overly
dramatic kiss bye
remember roses and roses here every
Tuesday with brand-new episodes from
Lauren your JC and myself